bonjour à tous place dans un instant à
une audition organisée par la mission
commune d'information sur le rôle et la
stratégie de l'Europe dans la
gouvernance mondiale d'internet c'est un
domaine dans laquel europeope est pour
l'instant très en retard face aux géants
américains même si l'Europe commence à
se doter une organisation et prévoit
pour 2020 un marché unique du numérique
pourtant et bien le retard reste
important et pour Catherine main de sa
rapporteur de cette mission commune
d'information il y a urgence à agir pour
que l'Europe ne devienne pas simple
consommateur d'un monde qui est en train
de nous échapper tout de suite donc
retour à cette audition qui s'est tenue
début mars au Sénat je crois qu'on va
s'exprimer au nom de des travaux qu'on a
mené ensemble notamment pour notre
ouvrage l'âge de la multitude et pas au
nom de nos missions responsabalités
respectives peut-être un très court
propos liminire effectivement c'est une
grande question et effectivement c'est
très intéressant de poser ces questions
de de gouvernance de souveraineté
d'organisation en en en intégrant
àinitio la la question industrielle j'ai
on se disait en préparant finalement il
y a une dizaine d'années encore la
question de la gouvernance d'Internet
était assez facileinnet c'était un
réseau de quelques millions de machines
qui
communiquaient avec un protocole de
d'interconnexion et les questions de
gouvernance étaient très proche des
questions d'architecture donc qui gère
le la racine le DNS est-ce que les
protocoles est-ce qu'on a garanti la
neutralité qui gère le nommage et avec
ces quelques questions on pouvait penser
une forme de régulation de neutralité
d'Internet aujourd'hui et ça c'est c'est
très important de c'est devenu la de se
le rappeler internet n'est plus internet
internet est sorti d'internet c'est la
trame de nos existences
c'est la trame de de P entier de
l'économie c'est la plateforme de très
nombreuses innovations sociales
économique et autres
et on peut plus contenter de le penser
comme une question d'infrastructure
notamment parce que c'est devenu un
enjeu de le théâtre d'affrontement de
stratégie industrielle et notamment
parce qu'aujourd'hui les les les
manières d'essayer de prendre le pouvoir
sur Internet se sont diversifié
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
espèces de points haut stratégiques qui
permettent d'exercer une forme de
domination et qui peuvent être du côté
des infrastructures ou ou de la des
couches profondes mais on voit bien qui
peuvent être en surcouchant Internet et
en en sortant des P entiers d'Internet
d'Internet aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
dans facebook c'est c'est sous droit
californien ça n'est plus tout à fait
Internet ce qui se passe dans un app
store quel que soit le le smartphone sur
lequel on est ça n'est plus tout à fait
internet il y a des pan du droit qui ne
sont plus les même on peut prendre le
pouvoir aussi par l'expérience
utilisateur par par des monopoles de faê
parfois sur des des choses très fines et
très ténues et il s'agit de de
réorganiser de la neutralité de la de la
concurrence de la possibilité
d'innovation du du respect des libertés
individuelles et des libertés publiques
dans un monde où les stratégies de
d'emprise ne se résument pas du tout à
la gouvernance des couches profondes moi
je vais juste donner trois trois
intuitions qui sont pas scientifiques
hein mais la première c'est que il
faudra peut-être un jour réussir à
penser le statut de ce curieux espace
public
c'est-à-dire ce numérique c'est ça n'est
plus tout à fait ça n'est pas seulement
un réseau technologique je l'ai dis il
s'interpénètre par l'Internet des Objets
il s'interface aujourd'hui avec les
corps avec les villes avec les maisons
avec le avec les
objets nous baignon dedans euh on a
parfois l'impression que son statut est
un peu impensé et certains enfin pour le
nommer Pierre Bellanger dans dans son
ouvrage sur la souveraineté numérique
rappelle la construction du droit des
océans il y a quelques siècles de cela
et et l'emprise britannique sur le droit
des océans et on a l'impression parfois
qu'il y a comme ça un milieu
interstitiel pas très bien pensé
deuxièmement il me semble enfin je me
permets de le dire de devant la
représentation nationale qu'on qu'on a
tendance à le ne pas trop le pas assez
le traiter comme un espace public
c'està-dire que il y a des des libertés
individuelles qu'on ne violerait jamais
dans dans l'espace public physique les
coffres des
voitures la liberté de circulation et
cetera et parce que c'est le numérique
on a parfois tendance à àit à les
sous-estimer à autoriser des régulations
un peu plus drastiques un peu plus
liberticide un peu plus rigide qu'on le
ferait dans un donc ça serait
intéressant de trouver un statut qui qui
le préserverait en tant qu'espace public
et puis enfin si on file la métaphore
des océan et ça va nous introduire sur
la question industrielle et et je vais
laisser la parole à Nicolas mais quoi
qu'on invente je pense qu'il y aura pas
de contrôle de ce milieu que je ne
saurais qualifier si on n pas une
appropriation réelle de ce milieu
c'est-à-dire si on a pas nos propres
vaissau qui le traverse qui qui l'occupe
qui savent s'en servir et donc si on a
pas une forme de puissance industrielle
sur ces milieuxlà comme là en
l'occurrence c'est aussi l'industrie qui
fabrique le milieu de toute façon on
sera toujours en en risque de de perdre
de souveraineté de d'incapacité à
défendre la la protection de la vie
privée d'incapacité à empêcher la
construction de monopole de fê ou de
distorsion de concurrence sur nos
propres entreprises et cetera et cetera
tous les problèmes qui sont en train
de se de voir le jour en ce moment était
connu et dénoncé par les les acteurs
économiques du secteur depuis 5 à 10 ans
et ils ont eu beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
à le prouver à se faire entendre à le
traduire dans une problématisation
juridique et donc si on n'est pas
totalement engagé dans la construction
de de cette économie et de cette
société on en est passif je sais pas si
j'irai jusqu'à dire qu'on en est une
colonie numérique mais en tout cas on
est au marge de l'Empire al Nicolas
voulait creuser deux aspects
particulièrement importants
oui je souhaitais reprendre à partir de
la notion de puissance industrielle pour
signaler
le la différence radicale qu' qu'il y
avait entre l'économie numérique
contemporaine celle que dans laquelle
nous vivons aujourd'hui et puis
l'économie numérique au moment où s'est
passé la révolution numérique dans les
années 90 dans les années 90 on était
dans un monde un peu bouillonnant où qui
était la compétition des start-ups
contre d'autres St up on avait des
start-ups qui réussissaient très bien et
puis qui sont devenus entre tempemps des
géants industriels on en a d'autres qui
sont devenus des géants puis qui ont à
nouveau disparu un très grand nombre
d'entre elles aux États-Unis ou en
France on en a jamais entendu parler
parce que bien qu'elles aient rencontré
des premiers utilisateurs bien qu'elles
alevé beaucoup de capital elles n'ont
pas réussi à se développer à une très
grande échelle et leur marque est restée
inconnue du grand public mais on on on
était dans une économie qui était
dominée par cette figure le créateur
d'une start-up dans son garage qui qui
avec un peu de capital part part en
cadre d'un grand marché euh d'une
certaine manière la France est un peu
restée prisonnière de cette image qui
est presque une image d'Épinal
euh récemment un un journaliste
économique de de de télévision qui est
Stéphane Soumier a consacré un éditorial
à ce sujet-là il a dit on en a marre des
start-ups ça fait 20 ans qu'on nous
parle de start-up ça fait 20 ans que nos
start-ups restent à l'état de start-up
et aucune d'entre elles n'est devenu un
géant industriel comme ont su le devenir
aux États-Unis les Google Amazon euh
Apple et Facebook on a bien sûr des
entreprises qui ont réussi à
s'introduire en Bourse à se ou à être
racheté par d'autres pour des montants
parfois légèrement supérieur à 1
milliard d'euros mais si on prend ce
montant- là comme un indicateur aux
États-Unis des statistiques montrent que
de la Silicon Valley est sortie de de la
sont sortis depuis 98 en moyenne une
entreprise tous les 3 mois qui à un
moment ou un autre de son existence a
valu plus d'un milliard de dollars donc
nous on en a peut-être une ou deux ou
trois euh eux ils en ont sortie une tous
les 3 mois depuis 98 et on ça provoque
la différence radicale entre l'économie
numérique d'aujourd'hui et celle d'hier
c'est qu'hier il y avait des start-ups
tout était ouvert ça mer c'était un
immense champ d'opportunités où tout le
monde avait sa chance aujourd'hui il y a
plus que des il y a plus seulement des
start-ups il y a des start-ups
et mais qui qui vivent autour de grands
piliers ou enfin de de grands géants de
géants industriels qui sont des
entreprises qui ont réussi passer là-bas
souvent grâce à la Bulet spéculative des
années 90 elles ont levé énormément de
capital elles se sont développé à très
grande échelle et elles sont installées
dans des positions dominantes sur des
marchés globaux et l'économie numérique
d'aujourd'hui donc n'est donc plus
seulement une question de start-up elle
est une question de géant industriel et
comme telle elle doit être prise très au
sérieux par nos dirigeants politiques
par nos capitaines d'industrie on n'est
plus seulement face à des jeunes qui
font des
apps pour pour jouer dans un coin on est
face à des des capital d'industrie qui
qui raésonne CIN ou six coup à l'avance
sur le grand échiquier de l'économie
mondiale euh on est face à des géants
industriels mais dans un régime très
particulier de l'histoire économique
c'est que ces géants industriels ne
semblent jamais parvenir à maturité
c'est-à-dire qu' continuent en
permanence de transformer leur modèle
d'affaires de s'étendre sur des nouveaux
marchés euh de réinventer leurs produits
de réviser leur
tarification et et donc dans cette
économie qui reste une économie de
l'innovation on est en
permanence à ce que les économistes
appellent la frontière de l'innovation
c'est-à-dire ce point au-delà duquel il
faut inventer par l'innovation les les
les gains de productivité qui permettent
à l'économie de continuer à se
développer et ça ça nous embarrasse
beaucoup nous Français qui avons
construit toute notre politique
industrielle sur la logique du
rattrapage tout notre développement
économique de des années 50 aux années
80 c'est'est construit sur l'imitation
la reproduction et le rattrapage de
l'économie américaine on a créé nos
champions pour imiter les champions
américains et progressivement nousisser
à leur niveau de performance et à leur
niveau de et à leur échelle d'opération
Dee façon assez classique le le grand
classique très connu c'est ils avaient
Boeing et ben nous on a créé Airbus et
un jour Airbus a finit par dépasser
Boeing en part de marché mondial la
question est maintenant qu'il y a Airbus
et Boeing qui se regardent en Chen
fillance qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment on
continue de développer notre économie il
nous suffit plus de rattraper les
Américains pourquoi parce que d'abord
les Américains sont irrattrapables
puisqu'ils innovent en permanence c'est
ça l'économie numérique ils sont en plus
irrattrapables parce que leur position
de marché ils les prennent plus
seulement sur un leur marché domestique
ils les prennent sur des marchés
mondiaux c'est-à-dire que le la
tentation permanente de dire puisqu'ils
ont Google il faut créer un Google
français est complètement veine parce
que Google ne fonctionne et n'est Google
que parce que il est en position
dominante sur un marché global et qui a
donc pas de place à la marge de Google
pour des entreprises qui ressemblent à
Google et ça c'est vrai pour tous les
géosindustriels de l'économie numérique
alors on pourrait se dire donc tout est
perdu toutes les places ont été prises
par les Américains l'histoire ne repasse
pas les plats et nous devenons une
colonie numérique ou une marche de
l'Empire en réalité c'est pas vrai parce
que les Américains d'une certaine
manière ont fait le plus facile
jusqu'ici ils ont
transformé les marchés qui étaient les
plus faciles à transformer pour le
numérique parce que le cœur de métier
des entreprises sur ces marchésl était
par nature profondément immatériel en
fait donc qu'est-ce qui a été transformé
les grands marchés qui ont été
transformés les grandes filières c'est
la publicité c'est la vente à distance
c'est toutes les industries de contenu
donc la musique l'audiovisuel le cinéma
le livre est en train de se transformer
devant nos yeux et d'une certaine
manière en transformant enfin en en
faisant émerger des géants qui ont pris
des positions dominantes sur ces
marchéslà les Américains ont fait le
plus facile ils ont fait quelques tours
d'échauffement et ils ont pris des
positions de façon assez précoce qui
leur
permettent acquérir une expertise un
savoir-faire dans ce que c'est que la
transformation numérique d'une filière
de l'économie nationale mais maintenant
et ça on le voit depuis quelques années
on rentre dans le dur dans les dans des
filières qui sont plus difficiles à
transformer parce que il suffit plus de
d'abandonner le CD et de et de créer le
MP3 il faut rentrer dans le la
complexité et la rigidité
d'infrastructure lourde d'environnement
réglementaire beaucoup plus complexe on
est dans la banque on est dans
l'assurance on est dans l'automobile on
est dans les infrastructures de
transport on est dans la santé tout ces
toutes ces filières là intéressent
beaucoup les géants du numérique mais
c'est plus difficile à transformer que
l'industrie musicale ou que la publicité
euh donc tout ça c'est pour dire que il
y a encore beaucoup d'opportunités qui
sont devant nous c'estd beaucoup de
filières qui restent à transformer et
dans lesquelles la messe n'est pas dite
c'est rien ne dit que le marché mondial
de la santé ou le marché mondial des
transports sera dominé demain par une
entreprise américaine c'est sur ces
marchésl dans la transformation numéque
est encore à venir qu'il reste des
opportunités pour des entreprises
françaises mais alors là se pose la
question ou européenne pardonnez
pardonnez mon chauvinisme mais euh c'est
là que se pose la question des
conditions de l'émergence des géants
industriels qui demain domineront les
filières numérique de de ou les marchés
numériques dans ces filières pas encore
transformé et et ces questions
d'écosystème sont très difficile parce
que elle recourt pas du tout au même
levier de politique économique ou de
politique industrielle que notre
ancienne économie de rattrapage dans une
économie de rattrapage on regarde ce que
font les les pays les plus avancés on
reproduit en laboratoires des
entreprises qui ressemblent aux
entreprises avancées on en fait des
champions nationaux en les soutenant par
des subventions publiques par par
différents instruments de
protectionnisme et on les amène jusqu'à
la frontière de l'innovation c'est ce
qu'on sont en train de faire aujourd'hui
les Chinois par du transfert de
technologie notamment nous on peut pas
faire ça pour les raisons que j'ai
expliqué et donc il faut qu'on
s'interroge sur comment faire émerger de
notre économie conomie nationale les
futurs champions numériques sur dans des
filières transformées on a trois grandes
options première option c'est les
start-up mais
jusqu'ici nous avons démontré notre
incapacité à faire passer des
entreprises de zéro jusqu'à l'infini
c'est-à-dire de d'une toute petite
entreprise créée dans un garage à un
géant industriel ça n'est jamais arrivé
en France et à ma connaissance en Europe
et donc il faut se poser des questions
sur notre marché du capital risque sur
notre droit du travail sur la
segmentation du du marché intérieur
européen sur un certain nombre de
rigidité ou de barrières culturelles
sociologiques qui explique que ça
manifestement ça ne marche pas le
deuxième option c'est les grandes
entreprises est-ce que les grandes
entreprises d'aujourd'hui qui sont des
entreprises matur sur des dans des
filières traditionnelles est-ce qu'elles
sont capables de devenir les champions
numériques une fois que leur filière
sera transformée est-ce qu'AXA est
capable de devenir le leader mondial de
l'assurance numérique est-ce que Vincy
est capable de devenir un leader mondial
du BT numérique euh là aussi la
transformation des des grands des
grandes organisations se heurte à
beaucoup de rigidité ça arrive parfois
les les géants industriels du numérique
américain nous nous montrent les plus
grands exemples les plus spectaculaires
de transformation d'une grande
organisation c'estd amazon a eu deux
phases dans son histoire elle a été un
géant du du commerce en ligne elle est
aujourd'hui un géant du Cloud Computing
donc elle a déjà réussi une
transformation radicale Apple s'est
transformé radicalement entre le Apple
des années 80 et le app que nouveau
logiciels qui émerg avec l'iPod et
iTunes et la distribution de musique il
y aement assez peu de points communs
donc cette transformation radicale nos
grandes entreprises sont-elles capables
de le pratiquer c'est c'est un peu une
éigme pour l'instant on est il y a peu
d'exemples qui qui nous encourage à le
penser la troisème option j'ai dit
start-up grandes entreprises la troisème
option ce sont nos PME c'est est-ce que
nos PME fragiles confrontés directement
à à à la mise en danger qui qui est
propre aux entreprises de taille petite
ou moyenne est-ce que elles-même dans
plus dans une logique de capitalisme
familial ou grâce à un marché actif et
profond du retournement d'entreprise
sont capable de transformer leur modèle
d'affairire à temps pour plutôt que de
de s'affaiblir et de disparaître
renaître sous la forme de de futur
champion qui vont commencer à croître de
façon exponentielle vous voyez donc les
les sujets de politique industrielle
qu'on soulève les start-ups c'est un
sujet de capital risque don un sujet
essentiellement de financement de
l'économie les grands groupes c'est un
sujet de je dirais de peut-être même
d'autorité politique c'est-à-dire est-ce
que les conversations que nos dirigeants
politiques avec nos dirigeants de
grandes entreprises sont centrés sur les
questions d'innovation et de
transformation radical aujourd'hui pas
vraiment ces conversations peuvent
naître et irriguer ou inspirer les nos
capitaines d'industrie et sur les PME
c'est plus des enjeux juridiques de
droits des faillites de de relation
entre les entreprises leurs créanciers
leurs actionnaires si une entreprise va
mal qu'est-ce qu'on en fait est-ce qu'on
la laisse mourir ou est-ce qu'on on
l'aide à renaître avec un nouveau
management un nouvel accenariat euh mais
ce sont des instruments de politique
industrielle qui aujourd'hui sont pas du
tout identifiés comme tel à tel encenne
que à beri Bery le le grand ensemble
Bery aujourd'hui la politique
industrielle est d'un côté le
financement de l'économie est de l'autre
ce sont deux ministères séparés qui CT
travaille très bien
ensemble dans la solidarité
gouvernementale qui s'impose mais le
simple fait les avoir séparé en deux
montre bien qu'on ne considère pas
forcément le financement de l'économie
comme un instrument de politique
industrielle or il est absolument
crucial ne serait-ce que pour pour faire
émerger des start-ups qui deviennent un
jour des enjeux des des géants
industriels
euh je finirai sur le le un deuxième
point très important qui est la question
de la confiance et de la protection des
données personnelles on s'est beaucoup
demandé et on change d'avis sur le sujet
à peu près d'année en année qu'est-ce
qui est le le cœur de l'économie
numérique qu'est-ce qui est le nerf de
la guerre dans l'économie numérique ou
le le carburant qui fait se développer
cette économie à une époque c'était les
réseaux c'était le dans les années
années 90 les opérateurs
télécommunications ont cru être les les
les champions du monde et et les les
entreprises les plus importantes dans
l'économie qui se transformait ensuite
on s'est dit c'est plutôt le logiciel
puis tout d'un coup on a vu renêître de
l'innovation matérielle avec les
smartphones et cetera ensuite on s'est
dit c'est le contenu donc ça explique
une stratégie la stratégie d'une
entreprise comme vivindiy qui s'est
centré sur le contenu et sur la valeur
qui s'attache au
contenu plus récemment et je pense que
l'année 2013 a été très marquée par ça
on a commencé à s'intéresser au données
personnelles la collecte des données et
à comment ces données servent à euh
consolider de la puissance
industrielle et ça je je je dirais que
ça ça ça attire notre attention sur un
point très
important et qui rejoint la thèse
centrale de l'ouvrage que nous avons
écrit qui est l'âge de la multitude
cette thèse elle est très simple c'est
de dire que la puissance industrielle
dans l'économie numérique se concentre
non pas à l'intérieur des organisations
mais dans la multitude c'est
c'est-à-dire nous tous qui sommes des
milliards d'individus équipés et
connectés et actifs dans notre
utilisation quotidienne d'application
numérique nous concentrons plus de
puissance nous individus que les
organisations et les organisations qui
les entreprises qui prennent l'avantage
dans cette économie sont celles qui
parviennent à nouer avec nous la
multitude une alliance et à nous enrôler
dans leur chaîne de valeur
euh je pense moi que le cœur de métier
des des grandes entreprises du numérique
n'est pas la technologie et à ce titre
c'est euh c'est trompeur de qualifier
euh ces entreprises d'entreprise
technologique ou le numérique de de
secteur technologique je pense que leur
cœur de métier est le lien privilégié
qu'elles savent nouer avec les
utilisateurs de leurs applications et la
collecte de données n'est qu'un
instrument dans la consolidation de ce
lien c'est-à-dire euh si on collecte des
données sur vous on sait mieux qui vous
êtes et parce qu'on sait mieux qui vous
êtes on va mieux vous servir
je pense que c'est pas du tout un hasard
si cette économie est dominée par des
entreprises américaines parce qu'on sait
que la culture américaine met très en
avant cette notion de la qualité du
service de la l'attention qu'on porte au
client on en a tous fait l'expérience
quand on a déjeuné au restaurant aux
États-Unis on est assailli par des
serveurs qui qui sont au petit soin pour
nous c'est beaucoup moins le cas en
France on n' pas cette culture là et et
d'une c que ce qu'amène en France et
géoindustriel américain c'est une une
qualit de service une
attention dans l'intimité des
utilisateurs à laquelle nous Français
sommes très mal habitués et et nous en
sommes
reconnaissant ça nous change de de notre
quotidien avec les entreprises
traditionnelles et c'est probablement
pas un hasard si nous sommes le pays où
les parts de marché sont les plus
importantes pour les entreprises qui
dominent l'économie numérique la part de
marché de Google moteur de recherche est
l'une des plus importantes en France si
on compare aux autr autres pays dans le
monde Apple a l'une des plus grosses
part de marché en France sur les
smartphones et sur l'écosystème mobiles
c'est parce que nous sommes très
accueillants pour ces entreprise qui
font enfin attention à nous et qui
cherchent à nous avec nous un lien
privilégié et par rapport à ce sujet de
la collecte des données personnelles qui
est un sujet industriel crucial on s'en
méfie beaucoup parce qu'on raisonne en
en en français en quelque sorte on pense
que si on collecte des données sur les
gens c'est pour leur faire du mal ou
pour leur leur pourrir la vie en leur
imposant des publicités intrusives
désagréable euh les entreprises
américaines collectent très peu de
données pour ça et collectent des
données pour rendre un service de
meilleure qualité plus personnalisé être
plus prévenant plus attentif et on
comprend pas l'économie numérique si on
comprend pas ce lien très fort qui se
noue entre les utilisateurs et les
entreprises qui opèrent les applications
utilisées au quotidien
euh pour cette raison-là je pense que
l'un des leviers de notre politique
industrielle c'est une protection très
importante des données personnelles
pourquoi ça parce que dans un
environnement juridique où les individus
sont très protégés face aux entreprises
les seules entreprises qui peuvent
réussir sont celles qui savent inspirer
confiance à leurs clients à leurs
consommateurs à leurs
utilisateurs c'est aujourd'hui le défi
n'arrive pas à relever nos entreprises à
nous nos banques nos opérateurs de
télécom nos assureurs nos opérateurs de
transport inspirer confiance à leurs
clients euh dans l'économie numérique on
ne réussit pas si on ninspire pas
confiance à ses utilisateurs le droit la
protection des données personnelles est
une barrière à franchir il faut inspirer
confiance pour pouvoir recueillir le
consentement des utilisateurs pour
utiliser leurs données pour mieux leur
rendre
service et on voit là à quel point on
touche à des enjeux culturels ou
sociologiques c'est la façon de penser
ce ce qu'est développer une entreprise
la façon de considérer les clients ou
les
utilisateurs par opposition au aux
actionnaires au aux partenaires aux
salariés il y a une sorte de prise
priorité qu'on doit apprendre à à donner
à au lien privilégié à nous avec les
utilisateurs pour avoir l'espoir qu'un
jour nos entreprises elles aussi
deviennent des géants industriels de
cette
économie est-ce que merci de cette
première ces deux premières
interventions je vais laisser la parole
à à Catherine main de juste juste un
point né aumoins pour la fin de votre
exposé vous avez décrit des modèles à
partir desquels peuvent s'envisager
l'évolution des des industries
l'industrie française vous l'avez pas
placé sur un plan européen justement un
moment donné vous avez corrigé en disant
soyons pas trop Chauvin c pas l'enjeu
naturellement mais est-ce que cette
approche on peut l'avoir sur une base
nationale est-ce qu'il faut l'avoir sur
une base européenne est-ce que ça a même
un sens de raisonner sur une base
nationale européenne encore aujourd'hui
par la réponse pour nous évidemment
positive mais je serais curieux de
savoir quel est votre
sentiment répondre très rapidement sans
d'ailleurs prétendre engager Henry qui
qui a peut-être un un avis différent
dans une économie où où où l'un des
principaux enjeux est de faire
émerger de de faire de toutes petites
entreprise de start-up des géants
industriels on il est important de
réaliser à quel point on travaille à
toute petite échelle à quel point on
tout ça s'inscrit dans des écosystèmes
très locaux très très ramassés où tout
compte le la recherche académique le
capital risque la culture
entrepreneuriale le soutien des des
pouvoirs publics tout ça est important
mais à toute petite échelle he la
silicone vallleée c'est une zone de 100
80 km sur 40 km c'est tout petit et
pourtant c'est là aujourd'hui que se
concentre toute la valeur créée par
l'économie numérique qui est en quelque
sorte capté dans le monde entier par les
applications et qui euh converge vers
cette zone ù par différents canaux et et
ça explique enfin ça explique d'ailleurs
toutes les tensions sociales il y a des
tensions sociales chez eux parce que les
riches deviennent de plus en plus riches
et ça devient insupportable pour les
autres il y a des tensions sociales chez
nous parce que les pauvres deviennent de
plus en plus pauvre parce que la marge
des entreprises est au plancher parce
que la valeur s'échappe via l'économie
numérique vers ces ces centres de
concentration enfin ces points de
concentration de la puissance
industrielle et notamment la silicone
vallleée mais ce que je veux dire en
disant ça c'est que on n pas besoin de
raisonner à très grande échelle on a
besoin d'un marché de déboucher pour
développer une application à grande
échelle mais les conditions d'émerg
d'une entreprise qui réussit ça on n pas
besoin de raisonner à l'échelle d' d'un
continent entier comme l'Europe ça se
fait à une toute petite échelle à
l'échelle d'une ville comme Paris à
l'échelle d'autres villes en France
peut-être qui qui ont des cartes à jouer
et je pense que tant qu'on attend de la
cordination à très grande échelle on
reste l'arme au pied et qu'on ne
commence pas ce travail indispensable
qui consiste à créer des écosystème
favorable à
l'innovation j'aimerais bien introduire
un nouveau thème qui serait sueli de la
souveraineté une souveraineté moderne
c'est un thème qu'on a un peu abandonné
je trouve de ce côté C de l'Atlantique
parce qu'on l'a confondu avec des formes
de protection un peu ringarde ou des
huettes or il y a aussi des formes de
souveraineté transactionnel dynamique
mobile et on est face à un continent
enfin un pays une fédération d'État qui
qui a une grande politique de
souveraineté d'abord il faut pas
l'oublier non plus le le numérique
américain c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent public beaucoup beaucoup
d'intervention publi beaucoup de
coopération militaro
privé de tous ordres le rôle de la DARPA
et cetera deuxièmement ça ça fait ça
rentre dans une stratégie cohérente de
de soft power d'exportation à la fois de
valeurs de technologie
d'idées et et je crois que nous il faut
qu'on apprenne de ce côté-ci de
l'Atlantique à à agir en peuple
souverain c'est et je vais répondre sur
l'Europe hein c'est-à-dire qu'on a nous
aussi des formes d'inven tion publique
qu'on qu'on doit pouvoir revendiquer on
doit avoir des libertés fondamentales
des points sur lesquels nous soyons
intraitables et nous sommes quand même
fondés à prétendre que sur notre
territoire les gens payent des impôts et
respectent la vie privée et quelques
autres choses si l'espace européen se
pensait comme un espace de souveraineté
ça serait formidable ça serait mieux
mais s'il se pense pas comme un espace
de souveraineté je je crois moi aussi
qu'on peut commencer à l'échelle d'un
pays et pour une raison simple c'est que
pour l'instant dans les modèles
économique actuel qui sont quand même
globalement fondés sur la publicité tout
dématérialisé que l'on soit et tout
réseau mondial que l'on soit on a
toujours une office une officine à Paris
qui prélève la la manne publicitaire
donc il y a toujours un moyen de
d'action d'intervention quelle que soit
la caractère mondialisé de l'entreprise
qu'on a en face de soi elle a un bureau
parisien qui est là pour encaisser les
recettes publicitaires donc on on peut
les prendre on peut discuter euh et on
est des marchés euh pas complètement
marginaux non plus enfin voilà on est 1
% de la population mondiale un peu plus
du PIB mondial si on a des
revendications euh légitimes on peut
discuter quoi donc je préférerais une
souveraineté européenne mais je n'en
vois pas donc il vaut mieux commencer en
France et ça n'engage que moi
oui encore que la la définition
peut-être de de la souveraineté euh
euh porte question enfin prête à
question euh à l'heure où il y a plus de
frontière euh en tant qu'État nation en
tout cas
euh j'avais une une
question par rapport à à l'analyse que
que vous faites de la transformation de
de nos industries en expliquant bien
qu'on a commencé par l'industrie du du
contenu et qu'aujourd'hui le plus
complexe resta à faire et que ça ouvrait
beaucoup de d'opportunités vous semblez
un petit peu à contre-courant d'un
Pierre Bellanger qu'on a qu'on a iné et
qui est beaucoup plus pessimiste nous
a-t-il semblé dans dans dans son
explication de la façon dont est en
train de se structurer justement la la
nouvelle économie numérique avec des
phénomènes de de de d'hyperccentration
euh et de de d'absence désormais de de
neutralité de de l'Internet euh il
évoquait le cas notamment de de
l'automobile par exemple et d'autres
exemples qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
nous dire de de de votre propre euh
appréciation par rapport à par rapport à
à cela qu'est-ce qui vous vous vous fait
être encore optimiste sur l'ensemble des
opportunités qui s'ouvrent devant nous
dans un monde très
monopolistique bon d'abord on a le droit
d'être pessimiste euh c'est et de croire
que les choses continueront ENF si vous
regardez bien d'abord l'histoire du
numérique c'est l'histoire de batailles
successives qu'on a pas forcément toute
perdu c'est-à-dire on a eu la bataille
sur les microprocesseurs l'Europe l'a
perdu la bataille sur les systèmes
d'exploitation on l'a perdu la bataille
sur les Télécom on a résisté euh sur les
réseau bataille du smartphone on l'a
reperdu bon donc à chaque bataille on a
l'impression que l'histoire n'est pas
forcément
joué inéluctablement alors Pierre
Bélanger lui il est très fasciné par la
convergence de tout ça dans ce qu'il
appelle les réseauogiciels donc il voit
une espèce de puissance d'attraction
gravitationnel qui qui pourrait avaler
les industries naissantes en tout cas
tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'à
l'heure où on se parle h si vous
regardez par exemple les objets
communiquants ces objets euh pétris
d'intelligence connecté en général
pilotés par la tablette ça c'est pas du
tout une spécialité américaine et vous
l'avez peut-être vu au dernier consumur
Electronic Show à Las Vegas quand W la
revue qui est notre Bible euh a présenté
les huit produits les plus cools les
coolest stuff de du du cons
electronicque il y en avait quatre
Français
euh donc là et et quand vous regardez
bien c'est mondial c'est-à-dire il y a
des PME pour l'instant de forte
croissance en France beaucoup en
Australie en Finlande aux États-Unis
mais pas spécialement dans la Silicon
Valley si vous regardez vers la médecine
dans ce qu'-là de le cœur artificiel par
exemple de création française c'est
juste une proesse mondiale
extraordinaire vous pouvez l'analyser
comme un objet intelligent hein c'est
quand même beaucoup d'électronique de
d'intelligence embarquée de de petites
interfaces si vous regardez les
questions alors là IBM à des positions
mais de de la ville du futur de la ville
intelligente déjà on a avantage c'est
qu'on a des villes on a des villes avec
des centres-villes avec de la diversité
sociale avec de de l'épaisseur
historique les États-Unis n'ont pas
beaucoup de ce que nous appelons des
villes en Europe concentré avec un
centre donc tous ces sujetsl en tout cas
on peut déjà dire que ce qu'on a sous
les yeux c'est que les les séquences
d'innovation qui naissent ne sont pas
californiennes après il y en a peut-être
qui peuvent considérer que la Californie
attrapera ça comme elle a attrapé
d'autres choses comme elle a repris le
téléphone et c'est un scénario possible
mais moi je ne pense pas qu'il soit
écrit alors moi je serais peut-être un
peu pas pessimiste comme Pierre béanger
mais un peu plus pessimiste qu'Henri je
pense qu'il faut surtout pas se rassurer
en considérant les médailles que
remportent les entreprises française au
consum Electronic Show ou le cœur
artificiel dont on a fait
l'expérimentation pilote mais pour
l'instant sans sans déploiement
industriel à grande
échelle c'est très dangereux dans un
pays passionné par la technologie
de d'applaudir trop vite les les
prouesses technologiques parce qu'on
pense que la technologie est une fin en
soi et que ça y est on a pris une
position de marché il n'en est rien
comme disait un ami à moi c'est pas
parce qu'on a vaut-il mieux inventer le
cinéma ou vaut-il avec les frères lumièr
ou vaut-il mieux inventer Hollywood
évidemment il vaut mieux inventer
Hollywood et le pays dans lequel a été
inventé le cinéma n'a aucune importance
dans la répartition de la puissance
industrielle de l'industrie mondiale du
cinéma donc la vraie difficulté c'est de
transformer ces prouesses technologiques
en modèles d'affaires qui qui sont
scalables comme disent les Américains
c'est-à-dire qu'il peuvent grandir à une
échelle globale et et attraire de la
valeur et la concentrer sur le
territoire pour qu'on puisse à nouveau
prélever des recettes fiscales créer des
emplois
redistribuer développer l'économie
nationale jusque moi je trouve qu'il est
pas du tout àodin que la semaine même où
quatre entreprises françaises étaient à
l'honneur dans Word au consumur
électronique Show de Las Vegas google a
racheté nest euh qui fabrique un
thermostat intelligent pour un montant
de 3,2 milliards de dollars donc il y a
ceux qui ramènent les médailles et puis
y a ceux qui font les les transactions
qui leur permettent de prendre des
positions industrielles majeures sur des
secteurs très prometteur euh et ça on ne
sait pas faire on ne sait pas faire
euh j'utilise deux chiffres pour
l'illustrer donc Amazon entre son
introduction en Bourse en 97 et son
premier exercice bénéficiaire en 2000
2003 a brûlé suivant le l'expression
dans dans dans le milieu a brûlé 3
milliards de dollars ils ont pu accéder
à ce capital sans faire de bénéfice
grâce à la bulle spéculative qui faisait
rage à l'époque mais on n pas forcément
besoin d'une bulle spéculative c'est
Facebook bien après l'éclatement de la
bulle technologique des années 90 entre
sa création et son introduction en
Bourse a brûlé 1,5 milliards de dollars
c'est ça le prix que coûte la
transformation d'une toute petite
entreprise en un géant industriel 3
milliards de dollars dans les années 90
1,5 milliards au milieu des années 2000
c'est à la à la fois c'est peu d'argent
c'est moins par exemple que le bénéfice
annuel d'une entreprise comme Orange
dont une partie revient à l'état pour
réduire le déficit budgétaire
euh mais en même temps c'est beaucoup
plus que ce à quoi n'importe quelle
entreprise sur notre marché qui se crée
parvient à lever jusqu'à parvenir à à
une très grande échelle d'opération
c'est nous n'avons pas les investisseurs
patient les marchés financiers profonds
qui permettent de prendre ces positions
industrielles et tant qu'on ne les aura
pas on fera les on produira les
meilleures technologies mais les modèles
d'affaires et les et les scalables
seront mis au point par les Américains
qui prendront les positions et si
nécessaire nous rachèterons les
technologies au bon
moment donc voilà et donc plus on avance
et plus le la puissance se concentre
dans ces quelques entreprises
américaines c'est-à-dire plus les autres
plus les opportun passe et plus il passe
vite on voit que Google sans jamais
avoir été vraiment présent dans le
secteur du bâtiment ou de l'énergie il
leur suffit d'acheter pour 3 milliards
une entreprise qui fabrique un
thermostat intelligent pour mettre un
pied dans cette chaîne de valeur et
probablement consolider une position en
aval de la chaîne puis progressivement
la remonté pour évincer les acteurs
traditionnels ils l'ont fait dans le BTP
ils l'ont ils s'intéressent beaucoup on
le sait à l'automobile euh et et quand
il rentre sur un marché souvent par une
acquisition Google ou les d'utres
grandes entreprises du numérique ils le
font avec énormément de capital
énormément de
savoir-faire logiciel de développement
un capital de marque et un lien
privilégié avec des centaines de
millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde
entier donc ça c'est c'est ça qui est de
plus en plus difficile à rattraper
c'estàdire tant
que l'une de nos entreprises en France
ou en Europe n'émerge pas pour se mettre
dans cette course là
euh ceux qui sont déjà creusent l'écart
mais je je vois aucune raison moi de
penser que c'est une fatalité pour
toutes les filières et pour et pour
toutes les décennies à
venir pas certain non plus qu'on est par
que je vis pas oublié ma question et je
voulais rebondir ce que disait monsieur
Collin est-ce que cette difficulté vous
pensez qu'elle elle vient du fait que
nous avons du mal en Europe en France en
Europe à appréhender la la révolution
très profonde que
constitue le numérique en tout cas la
ition que c'est une force profondément
transformatrice de toutes les
l'économie je je pense oui parce que je
pense qu'on ne comprend
pas on comprend pas la profondeur de la
transformation qui doit nécessairement
arriver pour qu'une entreprise existante
ou nouvelle prenne une position de
marché en faveur de notre
économie on peut en même temps applaudir
les entrepreneurs et dire l'innovation
c'est important et c'est la PR priorités
des priorités et cetera pendant ce
temps-là on continue néanmoins d'adopter
des règles ou des lois ou des des
décrets qui sont entièrement conçus pour
freiner le développement de de nouveaux
entrants sur des marchés où les intérêts
des entreprise en place sont
menacé à un moment donné alors aux
États-Unis il font il se passe la même
chose c'est les entreprise en place vont
toujours voir le régulateur ou les
pouvoirs publics pour demander la
protection réglementaire ou finan finci
de leurs intérêts sauf qu'en face ils
ont des gens beaucoup plus riches
beaucoup plus agiles qui financent
massivement les campagnes électoral des
dirigeants politiques et
donc l'innovation finit par
triompher je dirais par l'argent mais
d'une certaine
manière on en voit paradoxalement des
effets vertueux c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui
les les élections ne sont Pasin les
campagnes électorales ne sont pas
financées seulement par les entreprises
prolière et les champions du BTP et ceux
qui défendent des intérêts rétrogrades
et sont financés par des entreprises qui
ont fait l'innovation une valeur et un
levier de développement et chez nous ce
rapport de force n'existe pas c'est les
innovateurs sont éparpillés inconnus euh
peu peu présent dans les palais
nationaux euh et dès qu'il commen à
faire mal c'estàdire à remettre en cause
des positions d'entreprise en place on
leur enfonce la tête sous
l'eau d'apparaître excessivement
optimiste ENF ce que j'ai dit je je
persiste c'est qu'on sent bien que
chacune de ces batailles industrielles
remet quand même un peu les compteurs à
zéro même si ceux qui certains peuvent
partir avec des positions hautes
stratégiques mais et que je pense pas
que les issues soient fatales et comme
je le dis dans les années 90 on a failli
réussir la bataille des télécom sauf que
et deuxièmement moi ce qui me rend un
peu optimiste c'est notamment
l'expérience que j'ai eu en président
pendant 6 ans le pôle de compétitivité
parisien des des industries de contenu
et de service numérique Cap Digital
honnêtement mais même sur 6 ans la
vitesse à laquelle j'ai vu se
transformer les jeunes générations euh
leurs attitudes leurs aptitude leur
rapport à l'entrepreneuriat et pour une
raison simple c'est que internet a aussi
donné une pluralité de maître
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes
qui veulent entreprendre en France
prennent des cours à Harvard regardent
des tê conférences il s'est passé aussi
une mondialisation de des mentalités qui
fait que même si les élites françaises
n'ont pas encore pris enfin d'ailleurs
européen
toute l'ampleur du virage numérique ça
change très très vite chez les jeunes
générations Nicolas Collin d'ailleurs
qui qui est inspecteur général des
finances ou presque pas
général fait partie d'une nouvelle
classe desénar comme on en avait pas il
y a 5 ans donc il illustre lui-même mon
optimisme ensuite c'est voulez dire par
là qu'il a annoncé au statut
d'inspecteur des finances pour créer un
incubateur vient il retourne c'est
compliqué mais il entreprend ça mérite
d'être souigné vous avez raisinval et
dans l'in et il
entreprend c'est là que de nouveau de la
politique et de et de la souveraineté au
bon sens du terme peuvent être des
atouts enfin un espace comme l'espace
européen mais s'il faut commencer par la
France eff fondé les Américains
sauraient l'entendre à défendre son
droit de la concurrence j'ai toujours
été très étonné du du peu de recours que
nous faisions au droit de la concurrence
à défendre sa vision de la liberté
d'expression pour ceux qui connaissent
les les subtilités de la loi bicher et
de tout ce qui encadre le le pluralisme
de la presse quand on sait que allez
Google plus Facebook ça fait plus de 60
% du trafic sur la plupart des sites
d'information et d'ind différence
générale c'est c'est très étonnant de
voir à quel point on et et je pense
qu'on pourrait dire voilà n nous sommes
sensible et attentif à à garantir le le
pluralisme de des opinions et la liberté
d'expression et on a reçu Monsieur
Almunia dans le cadre de cette mission
avec une autre commission on n' pas eu
le sentiment que par rapport à Google
par exemple il était terminer à mener un
combat poussé jusqu'à son terme sur les
question de concurrence malheureusement
ça va je pense qu'il y a quelques choses
mais il faudrait revenir à des principes
fondateurs à des principes sur les
libertés publiques les libertés
individuelles le droit de la presse le
droit de la concurrence et puis les
faire valoir en tant que principe et ça
n'est pas ça me rappeler dans les années
90 l'Allemagne sur des sujets liés à
l'environnement c'était fait presque une
spécialité de de s'imposer des normes et
puis de les exporter d'abord dans
l'Europe et parfois des normes sur le
recyclage des normes sur les dioxines
des normes sur et leurs industries
étaient préparées parce qu'ils avaient
d'abord construit une sorte de de de
test en incubateur national il
s'appliquaient d'abord les normes à
l'échelle de leur pays et puis il les
exportai et je continue à penser que
c'est une position que l'Europe pourrait
envisager et que effectivement euh
l'attention à la protection des données
personnelles mais à quelques autres
droits aussi peut devenir un avantage si
on sait le jouer comme tel
quoi
oui vous avez
évoqué sans doute la nécessité d'un
statut pour ce nouvel espace public
constituer le que constitue le le le
cyberespace selon quel principe
précisément c'est ce que vous venez de
d'évoquer
ou je parle pas de choses sur lesquelles
je serais ni légitime ni mandaté mais à
titre personnel j'ai souvent été étonné
de du nombre de de de choses qui qu'on
décidait sur Internet et qui seraiit des
mesures d'exception profondément
liberticide si on les faisait dans le
monde réel quoi de surveillance qu'on
autorise du nombre de débranchag qu'on
autorise du nombre de de et ça m'a
toujours étonné de voir que ce qui pour
les les jeunes générations et et
l'espace dans lequel ils se meuvent et
s'expriment et rencontrent les autres et
construisent leur identité était souvent
pensé comme si c'était une espèce de
d'espace extrêmement tech logique qu'on
pouvait réguler beaucoup plus sévèrement
et donc je trouve qu'il y a je vous
parle pas enendroit là mais dans dans
les représentations inconsciente dans
les imaginaires qui encadrent la la
régulation du numérique on se dit pas
bah finalement c'est un espace public et
d'ailleurs ça marche dans les deux sens
par exemple on peut aussi être terrifié
de rappeler que l'expression des propos
racistes ou antisémite est un délit dans
dans un espace public et on n'ose pas le
dire sur Twitter parce que on sait plus
ce que c'est et pour moi faute de mieux
c'est
c'est pas plus bête qu'autre chose de le
penser comme un espace public voilà dans
lequel il y a il y a des expressions qui
sont des délis mais il y a aussi des des
protections qui sont
garantis je voulais interroger monsieur
Collin sur l'aspect fiscal que vous avez
un peu évoqué tout à l'heure suite aux
travaux que vous vous avez
menés la question fiscale elle elle est
lié forcément à à la question des des
entreprises qu'on a évoqué euh est-ce
que la forme de fiscalité assiste sur
les données notamment est-ce que ça a
évolué en matière de l'applicabilité
voilà de ce que vous avez préconisé
est-ce qu'il y a eu des des poursuites à
vos travaux si je pe si je peux ajouter
juste un élément à cette question vous
évoqué tout à l'heure la la question de
la captation de valeur et vous évoquez
notamment le travail de monsieur béonger
lui s'inquiète très clairement dans son
ouvrage non seulement d'une captation
mais quasiment d'une quasi disparition
d'une valeur vraiment active et
dynamique dans nos économies européennes
au profit euh de ces systèmes est-ce que
vous partagez cette ce sentiment est-ce
que la fiscalité de nature a a apporté
une
réponse
euh je pense pas que la fiscalité à elle
seule peut corriger les profonds
déséquilibres qui sont en train de
s'installer en matière de répartition
mondiale de la valeur
euh
pour
oui c'est c'est juste mais le le travail
sur la fiscalité pour moi il a été très
révélateur parce que quand on
s'intéresse à la fiscalité des grandes
entreprises on se pose des questions
élémentaires très simples qui est
qu'est-ce qui crée la valeur qu'est-ce
qui crée la valeur ajoutée et qui
contribue donc à générer les bénéfices
d'une
entreprise il y a toute une discipline
pour déterminer ça notamment tout ce qui
est le les prix de transfert mais qui
repose sur pour l'essentiel sur une une
vision en partie périmée de ce que c'est
que la création de valeur dans
l'économie c'est-à-dire on attache
beaucoup de valeur à la propriétés
intellectuelles aux actifs
tangibles bref à tout ce qui se
concentre dans les organisation or comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et c'est
c'est la thèse centrale de notre ouvrage
nous pensons que dans l'économie
numérique révèle une une une valeur qui
est de plus en plus à la lisière voire à
l'extérieur des organisations et les et
mais ça n'empêche pas les entreprises de
faire levier de l'activité des individus
et donc de d'attraper cette valeur à
l'extérieur pour la réinsérer dans leur
chaîne de valeur et ainsi contribuer à
générer des bénéfices donc il y a tout
un raisonnement comme ça qui consiste à
revisiter les les les facteurs de la
création de valeur et à réaliser que
dans le
numérique ces facteurs ne sont pas
seulement dans les entreprises donc là
où elles ont leurs sièges sociaux ou
leurs établissements stables mais aussi
là où sont les utilisateurs qui sans
sans être des clients qui payent sont
sont des agents actifs en fait de la
produc de la chaîne de production
euh alors ça c'est une vision très
fidèle à ce que les économies numériques
pensent d'elles-même c'est ce que tous
les grands blogueurs et les grands
auteurs et les grands conférenciers et
les grands entrepreneurs du numérique
euh disent quand ils expliquent quelle
est leur activité leur activité consiste
à s'allier avec des utilisateurs pour
ensemble cocréer de la valeur mais
jusqu'ici ça n'est pas du tout tout
parvenu ou à peine jusqu'aux communautés
des gens qui font la fiscalité ceux qui
font le droit ceux qui le pratiquent euh
le rapport que j'ai coécrit avec Pierre
Collin conseiller d'État a a permis de
quelques progrès de ce point de vue-là
c'est-à-dire de de mettre devant les
yeux des professionnels de la fiscalité
une analyse de la chaîne de valeurs
adaptée à ce que l'économie numérique
aujourd'hui à telle encienne que le
enfin l'analyse elle-même a été endossée
par le gouvernement et est porté devant
les instances de l'OCDE dans le cadre
d'un chantier de remise à plat de la
fiscalité des grandes entreprises
multinationales qui s'appelle BES comme
base erosion and profit shifting
c'est-à-dire érosion des bases fiscales
et transfert de bénéfices euh pour
l'instant néanmoins le
chantier a des ambitions modestes il
s'agit de partager un diagnostic à
l'échelle des états-memes de l'OCDE
c'estd le travail qui a été fait euh je
pense de façon assez profonde et et avec
beaucoup de d'implication des uns et des
autres en France et en
fait diagnostique sur ce qu'est
l'économie numérique et qu'est-ce que la
fiscalité nous révèle sur la répartition
de la valeur et comment la fiscalité
peut doit s'adapter pour mieux épouser
la création de valeur dans l'économie
numérique on l'a fait en France à
travers le rapport que j'ai coécrit puis
les travaux du Conseil national du
numérique puis les débats qui ont eu
lieu y compris dans cette maison
notamment à l'instigation du président
Marini il faut maintenant refaire le
travail de diagnostic parce que rien ne
peut se faire sans un diagnostic partagé
c'est fait au niveau européen à
l'initiative du commissaire Semeta qui a
formé un groupe d'experts pour pour se
faire dont fait partie pierre Collin et
c'est fait au niveau de l'OCDE dans le
cadre du chantier BEPS mais sans autre
mandat que celui de formuler un
diagnostic sur comment crét-on la valeur
dans l'économie
numérique fait une toute petite
remarque même si finalement dans l'â de
la multitude on montre que le secret cré
des géants de numérique c'est souvent de
on peut le résumer autour du travail
gratuit he que ce soit direct indirect
conscient inconscient consenti pas
consenti on aurait tort d'aller trop
loin dans un raisonnement qui verrait
dans ces entreprises des entreprises
prédatrices uniquement et de vouloir
réguler en disant bah il nous vole de la
valeur il nous vole des données et il
faut les en
empêcher d'abord il faut enfin il y a
une contribution assez volontaire des
des internautes des entreprises ou des
particuliers et en général ils peuvent
se tromper mais ils le font parce qu'ils
estiment euh que dans une balance
équilibrée ils y gagnent aussi et c'est
des entreprises qui vous donnent des
choses en contrepartie du fait que que
vous leur donnez des données je sais pas
on pourrait donner beaucoup d'exemples
nous on a été assez fasciné par le un
petit calcul de qu table
euh je sais pas à combien on est
maintenant d'applications disponibles
dans l'App Store d'Apple on doit tutoyer
le le million d'applications donc si
elles ont coûté 6 mois hommes de
développement par exemple je sais pas du
tout hein si c'est 6 mois ou 1 an ou ça
veut dire qu'il y a 500000 années
ingénieur euh là-dedans qu'Apple n'a pas
payé et sur lesquels il prend 30 % du
chiffre d'affaires alors on pourrait se
dire quelle prédation mais en même temps
il a donné à 500000 ingénieurs la
plateforme de leurs rêve pour faire des
choses qu'ils auraient jamais osé
imaginer faire c'est-à-dire quelque
chose qui calcule qui géolocalise qui
communique qui prend des photos qui qui
a une un gyroscope une boussole et
cetera et cetera et un accès au marché
qu'ils auraient dont ils auraient jamais
pu rêver
et donc comme certains sociologues le
disent en ce moment la question elle est
peut-être de se
dire ce sont des choses que les les
utilisateurs considèrent comme des
équilibres fondés on peut pas juste
analyser ça en terme de prédation il
faut peut-être se mêler en revanche pour
aider les gens à faire des négociations
collectives et c'est d'autant plus
important que parfois cette prédation de
données finalement à titre individuel on
l'abandonne parce que à titre individuel
ça n'est pas grave le savoir vient de de
ce qu'on a les donné de millions de gens
savoir que je suis tel jour à telle
heure dans tel restaurant n'a aucune
importance et je le conselle bien
volontiers pouvoir analyser la
déformation du comportement alimentaire
des Français dans la longue durée a
beaucoup d'importance mais c'est parce
qu'on a tous donné nos données que ça a
de l'importance et je pense qu'il va
plutôt falloir aller vers réfléchir sur
comment harmoniser des négociations
collectives entre le les peuples la
multitude vous l'appelez comme vous
voulez et ces plateformes géantes plutôt
que de dire je dois freiner cette
prédation et empêcher le transfert de
données et et et casser cette économie
naissante ù où quand même et je termine
avec ça les gens contribuent parce
qu'ils pensent y trouver leur compte et
parce que d'une certaine manière ils y
trouve leur
compte par ailleurs pour pour rebondir
sur la fiscalité peut-elle corriger le
déséquilibre que l'on assiste en matière
de répartition mondiale de la valeur je
pense pas que la fiscalité seule suffise
à ça d'abord parce que la fiscalité
soulève des questions microéconomique
bien connu d'incidence c'està-dire c'est
pas parce qu'on a qu'on assoit un impôt
sur un ass ti que c'est c'est cet
assujetti qui doit le sortir de sa poche
très souvent l'assujetti a la capacité
de répercuter le montant de l'impôt sur
un autre acteur de son
écosystème et et et jusqu'ici c'est
toujours ça qui s'est passé c'est-à-dire
par exemple Amazon aux États-Unis est de
plus en plus sujette à l'obligation de
collecter des taxes sur les ventes sur
les sur les ventes qui réalisent dans un
certain nombre d'États
américain ça a été analysé ça comme une
VI initialement comme une victoire
industrielle pour les entreprises
auxquelles Amazon fait concurrence
notamment les commerces traditionnels en
réalité amazon a retourné à son avantage
ce qui est pe être considéré comme un
handicap en disant quitte à à devoir
payer des à collecter des des taxes sur
les ventes dans tous les États où j'ai
une implantation physique et bien je
vais multiplier les implantations
physiques sur tout le territoire
américain pour raccourcir mes délais de
livraison et évincer mes concurrents par
par une promesse très simple qui est
vous êtes livré de plus en plus le jour
même par Amazon le jour même de la
commande euh
donc donc on voit bien que la fiscalité
en fait très souvent comme toute
perturbation dans un système renforce
l'effort et affaiblit les faibles en
tout cas c'est très souvent ce qui se
passe en matière de fiscalité des
entreprises et donc la fiscalité est
plus un
révélateur disons ça devrait être un
signal d'alarme de voir qu'on narrive
plus à prélever des recettes fiscales
sur les plus grandes entreprises
mondiales alors même qu' qu'elle crée de
la valeur sur notre territoire enfin
aucune partie de leur processus de
création de valeur est sur notre
territoire et donc ça c'est c'est une
alerte qui doit nous inspirer l'idée
selon laquelle ce serait important
d'avoir aussi nos propres entreprises
mondiales qui créent de la valeur
partout dans le monde et qui la
concentre ici sur notre territoire parce
que toutes les entreprises du monde de
tous les secteurs et de tous les pays
optimisent leur fiscalité et minimisent
leur exposition fiscale dans les pays où
elles n'ont pas leur siège
l'optimisation fiscale dans le secteur
bancaire nous convient très bien parce
que euh les banques américaines
optimisent leur fiscalité et payent très
peu d'impôts ici mais nous avons nos
banques français qui payant très peu
d'impôts à l'étranger concentrre
l'essentiel de leur recette fiscale ici
en France le problème dans le numérique
vient du fait que toutes les entreprises
qui dominent le numérique sont sont dans
un seul pays et c'est comme ça que se
crée le déséquilibre et que et que nous
devons être mis en alerte sur le fait
que en même temps que les recettes
fiscales
disparaissent d'une certain manière le
même phénomène est à l'œuvre pour les
emplois pour les pour les salaires pour
le revenu national d'une manière
générale et l'appauvrissement que nous
ressentons tous et que ressentent tous
les français et ça je pense que ça se
voit dans dans les études et dans dans
toutes les interactions que vous pouvez
avoir avec avec nos nos concitoyens
l'appauvrissement général il est il est
aussi il est une sensation fidèle à ce
qui se passe macro-économiquement
c'est-à-dire que à mesure que la
transformation numérique de l'économie
progresse la valeur s'échappe là où sont
les sièges des entreprises qui dominent
cette économie et tant qu'aucune de ces
entreprises n'est chez nous euh nous ne
pouvons pas compter sur cette valeurl
merci beaucoup enfin je sais pas si
Catherine avait d'autres questions on
arrive presque au terme mais on peut
éventuellement question sur ce que vous
évoquez être le droit des des
plateformes les suggestions que vous
proposez de leur imposer dans quel cas
cela pourrait-il se se
constituer
a il y a deux manières de
répondre d'abord la puissance publique a
très longtemps su imposer des
suggestions aux entreprises qui
devenaient trop puissantes et dont dont
l'activité devenait essentiel à à toute
l'économie je suis assez frappé moi et
j'ai j'ai d'ailleurs exprimé des chose
pas plus pas plus tard que ce matin dans
une autre
réunion sur la la
similarité qui existe entre le
fonctionnement de ces plateformes et les
principes du service public alors ça
peut vous sembler très éloigné mais vous
savez les grands principes du service
public sont au nombre de trois ils ont
été théorisés par un grand professeur de
droit qui s'appelle Louis Roland et ces
grands principes sont la continuité donc
on connaît bien la mutabilité
c'est-à-dire le fait que le service
public peut changer il y a personne n'a
le droit à la permanence et du service
public mais il peut changer de d'un jour
à l'autre si le contexte a changé si la
volonté du législateur n'est plus la
même et puis troisème principe c'est
l'égalité ces trois principes se
retrouvent dans dans le fonctionnement
de cette plateformes c'est que jusqu'ici
elles ont compris que leur succès
industriel passait par la continuité il
faut s'engager à lauitité du service
c'est aucun développeur ne va développer
l'application sur le sur l'iPhone si
l'iPhone ne fonctionne pas un jour sur
deux euh la mutabilité c'est-à-dire on
change de temps en temps parfois on met
à jour le système d'exploitation et tout
le monde doit s'adapter le millions de
développeurs qui ont développé des
applications doit le cas échéant changer
ses applications pour suivre l'évolution
fonctionnelle du système il y a aussi
l'égalité c'est-à-dire le fait que
n'importe qui peut ouvrir un compte chez
Apple et développer une application il y
a pas de négociation préalable de
gréagré où Apple va demander mais qui
êtes-vous exactement montrez-moi vos
derniers bilans est-ce qu'on est sûr que
votre application a de la valeur ajoutée
et ça c'est un facteur très important de
la puissance industrielle de ces
plateformes c'est qu'elle laisse tout le
monde venir s'emparer de leur ressources
pour créer plus de valeur avec elle et
ça c'est un trait culturel qui est
complètement absent de de nos capitaines
d'industrie à nous qui ne savent pas
innover avec d'autres en laissant les
autres faire ce qu'ils veulent avec
leurs ressources sans négociation
préalable de gré à gré euh et pour cette
raisonlà parce que ces plateformes
ressemblent beaucoup au service public
finalement elle prêtent très peu le flan
à des impératifs de de régulation il y a
peu de choses à réguler parce que tout
fonctionne déjà pas mal en
fait juste introduire un thme qui est
peut-être éloigné de vos préoccupations
mais qui me préoccupe moi c'est que sans
faire de de science-fiction trop
radicale je pense qu'on est à quelques
années de voir certaines de ces
plateformes venir défier la puissance
publique dans ses prérogatives de
puissance publique c'estàd prétendre
gérer l'identité forte des citoyens en
proposant des Facebook Connect ça existe
en Angleterre he pour pour se connecter
à certains services publics prélever
l'impôt donc tu as dit que ça commence
sur certaines taxes et cetera et cetera
et donc il faut peut-être aussi
s'interroger en disant euh quelles sont
les choses que nous voulons
maintenir à la puissance publque
c'est-à-dire dans quand même l'organe
qui est chargé de défendre l'intérêt
général qui est mandaté par les citoyens
et par les électeurs et je pense que ça
va arriver plus vite qu'on ne le pense
et que sans réflexion ad dooc là-dessus
il y aura des des abandons de
souveraineté inconscient et et
difficilement réversible et avec un
impératif c'est que les citoyens et très
peu et l'administré sont très peu
tolérants au à la différence de qualité
de service entre l'expérience
fluide immédiate rassurante et
personnalisée qu'ils éprouvent tous les
jours dans les applications numériques
et puis la rigidité et la la lenteur et
la lourdeur bureaucratique des
guichets habituels auquel il se
confrontent quand il se tourne vers la
puissance publique l'une des raisons qui
fait que
la la souveraineté se transfère
progressivement vers ces plateformes
c'est qu'elles apprennent aussi à mieux
rendre les services publics aux citoyens
identifier un citoyen pour pour lui
épargner d'avoir à fournir des
photocopies de et de justifiant son
domicile ça c'est un service
extraordinaire que tout le monde
apprécie parce qu'on a tous pesté en
faisant en faisant la queue derrière un
guichet administratif et d'avoir oublié
de photocopier le le bon formulaire euh
ces entreprisesl évincent les les
entreprises trop bureaucratiques en en
imposant cette fluidité et cette
personnalisation et c'est un défi pour
la puissance publique qui doit
euh euh qui qui doit se mettre à niveau
et et proposer aux citoyens une qualité
de service égale si elle veut parvenir à
préserver la souveraineté euh alors on
entend beaucoup et beaucoup trop je
trouve l'idée surelon laquelle mais nous
sommes l'état nous sommes lourds nous
sommes lents nous sommes pauvres il est
normal que nous soyons en retard je
pense qu'il y a aucune raison que l'État
soit en retard en terme de qualité de
service et de performance sur ses
entreprises je pense même que dans la
tradition française du service public on
a on on a longtemps été habitué à l'idée
que l'État était plutôt en avance sur
les les entreprises parce que il y avait
la volonté politique parce qu'il y avait
les ressources concentrées grâce à la
centralisation aujourd'hui c'est il y a
une sorte de sentiment d'abandon on
baisse les bras et on renonce à une
qualité de service et à un lien
privilégié avec l'administré ou le
citoyen qui est pourtant essentiel si on
veut préserver ses prérogatives nous
recevons après Nicolas CIN et HRY
vertier madame natell chich qui est
membre du Conseil économique social et
environnemental et e certaine manière de
nous a brûlé la politesse puis qu'elle
vient de publier un rapport justement
sur la gouvernance d'Internet pour une
gouvernance ouverte et équitable donc
j'espère que tout n'est pas dit dans
votre rapport sinon nous n'aurons plus
qu'à le le recopier c'est ce que nous
allons essayer de vérifier en vous
écoutant cette après-midi donc je vous
laisse tout de suite la parole peut-être
pour nous faire part de vos réflexions
et conclusions pu on pourra échanger
comme il est d'usage dans la dans la
foulée merci beaucoup d'être d'avoir
répondu à à notre invitation alors c'est
vrai qu'on a beaucoup entendu par par
dans l'actualité de protection des
données de neutralité du net de
cybercriminalité et il se trouve que la
gouvernance d'Internet empacte t ces
sujets et que c'était intéressant de
prendre une de d'envisager ce sujet d'un
point de vue global et d'essayer de voir
comment interagissaiit
justement les acteurs les différents
acteurs que j'ai identifié donc dans
cette étude dans cet écosystème qui est
internet alors écoutez pour être pour
être assez exhaustive parce que j'ai
essayé quand même euh voilà je me suis
dit bon j'ai regardé un petit peu la
liste des auditionnés que vous avez eu
très prestigieux don Michel ser ça me
paraît je suis honoré de faire partie
d'une de d'être auditionné devant cette
mission où Michel ser a été auditionné
je me suis dit bon qu'est-ce que je
pourrais proposer de plus à cette étude
alors et je vous réserve ça pour la
deuxième partie de ma de ma présentation
euh pour justement essayer de faire
avancer un petit peu les choses parce
que vous savez c'est cette étude je l'ai
fini fin novembre c'était juste après
monté vidéo la déclaration de monté
vidéo c'était on sait pas encore
justement il y a bientôt donc le forum
au Brésil et je me suis dit qu'est-ce
que je peux faire qu'est-ce que voilà
quelles sont les réflexions que je peux
apporter de plus à cette mission pour
justement essayer de justement de vous
donner de vous passer le relais donc
voilà alors écoutez voilà ce que ce que
vous avez si vous avez mon mon étude
vous avez vu que j'ai identifié donc bon
j'ai identifié le fait
qu'Internet comme l'ont dit Henri Henri
Verdi et Nicolas Collin le monde de
l'Internet on sait qu'il ne fonctionne
pas comme le monde physique et que ce
internet donc est un réseau qui se
déploie dans un espace international et
qui est techniquement sans
frontières je j'entends par parler de
souveraineté j'entends parler de
gouvernance on sait qu'Internet est
entre en tension permanente avec le
système vfalien qui est fondé lui sur la
notion de souveraineté des États donc il
faudra peut-être clarifier peut-être que
je l'ai pas fait dans mon étude la
différence entre souveraineté et
gouvernance pour exemple j'ai pensé que
c'était intéressant je l'ai pas mis dans
mon étude en 2002 193 pays sur 93 pays
seulement qure voulaient avoir le droit
d'exercer une censure sur le contenu
d'Internet 10 ans après donc au moment
de la conférence de Dubaï 193 pays sur
les 193 pays 40 demandent le droit
d'exercer une censure sur le contenu
d'Internet donc en fait on se rend
compte qu'en 10 ans il y a une une
multiplication par 10 des pays qui
veulent censurer Internet et cela ça
s'explique sûrement par l'extension des
usages sur un Internet et puis surtout
la montée à mon avis en puissance des
grands acteurs commerciaux dont on a
parlé les les fameux grands acteurs
américains qui euh sont très menaçants
pour les
états donc en fait dans notre étude on
est on a on a identifié trois grands
acteurs qui sont les acteurs économiques
euh qui sont donc les fournisseurs
d'accès à Internet et les fournisseurs
de contenu qui se vivre une bataille une
commerciale sans merci et et donc on
sait que c'est géants du Net consolide
leur position en croisant leurs données
personnelles dont il disposent sans que
l'utilisateur n'en ait
conscience
pour bon je reviendrai pas sur ce qui a
été dit sur les gafas sur les
législations fiscales et cetera ce que
je pourrais dire simplement et pour
illustrer un petit peu les propos de
cette hégémonie de ces acteurs
économiques qui ont pris un poids
considérable je reprendrai un petit peu
la phrase prophétique de de Eric Schmidt
qui est le patron de Google et qui dit
il ne nous laisse pas être un
gouvernement donc c'est vrai que on on
peut s'interroger sur ce genre de
prédiction euh on peut constater aussi
que les entreprises américaines sont
très présentes à Bruxelles donc et elles
font un lobbying très intensif par
rapport aux
entreprises qui sont beaucoup moins
structurés que ces que ces
Gafa et en fait ce peut aussi préciser
et que j'ai eu l'occasion donc de
constater lors de mes auditions c'est
que il y a une divergence et un manque
d'unité au sein de l'Union européenne
qui rend très difficile l'avancement
comme la proposition de règlement sur
relatif à la protection des personnes
physiques à l'égard du traitement des
données à caractère personnel et la
libre circulation des données sans
parler de la question de l'optimisation
fiscale dont parlait madame Maine de sa
tout à l'heure à Nicolas
Collin à part les acteurs économiques la
deuxème catégorie ce sont les état
naationss on constate que les étatntion
ils sont venus assez tard ils ont
compris un petit peu
tard les enjeux d'Internet et on se rend
compte que les notions traditionnelles
de territoire et de frontières sont très
peu opérante dans un superespace qui
s'affranchit des frontières
géographiques on sait qu'Internet n'a
pas de
frontières et
euh on a remarqué donc Internet est donc
en tension permanente avec les
prérogatives
des États et les choses se sont
cristallisées beaucoup plus au moment de
la conférence de Dubaï parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte qu'en fin de compte il y
avait deux blocs qui se sont vraiment
affrontés d'un côté les pays occidentaux
avec les États-Unis avec l'Union
européenne et la France et les pays
occidentaux qui eux se sont opposés à un
contrôle accru d'Internet et de l'autre
côté les pays émergents et les pays en
voie de développement qui eux sont
attachés à ce pouvoir souverain et qui
souhaitent et qui et qui sont donc très
attachés au au contrôle du
fonctionnement d'Internet le cas le plus
flagrant étant la Chine qui elle a créé
ses propres structures au sein d'un
immense intranet donc on le voit la
Chine la Russie rejoint par les pays
émergents eux sont affirment la
prédominance la prééminence des états
sur les autres acteurs et entre les deux
on a des pays qui sont indécis qui n'ont
pas vraiment de position sur
sur sur donc le contrôle d'internet et
c'est assez dangereux parce qu'ils sont
quand même d'un certain nombre et ils
peuvent être une cible pour ces pays
justement pour ces pour ces deux blocs
qui s'affrontent et et pour justement
les raller à leur
position donc pour revenir à notre sujet
qui nous intéresse et qui est donc la
une mission donc sur le nouveau rôle à
la nouvelle stratégie pour l'Union
européenne je pense que pour l'Union
européenne elle elle a toujours affiché
son son sa volonté d'être un
interlocuteur engagés dans les
négociations internationales sur la
gestion la seule chose c'est qu'on a
remarqué lors du dernier la dernière
préparation vous savez du Conseil
européen sur le numérique Fleur Pellerin
avait essayé de préparer un un un mini
sommet juste avant et on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait que 6 ou se pays
qui avaient qui étaient venus pour cette
préparation de ce
miniommet sur les 27 maintenant 28 c'est
vrai que c'est pas c'est pas beaucoup je
peux citer l'Allemagne le Royaume-Uni
l'Espagne l'Italie la Pologne la Hongrie
et la BEL Belgique voilà c'est on peut
compter sur ces SEP pays qui sont
vraiment concernés par les enjeux par
par par le numérique et sinon les autres
c'est un petit peu compliqué donc il
faudrait peut-être s'interroger comment
essayer de les justement de les de les
intéresser et puis le troisème acteur
c'est la société civile on l'a vu elle a
une importance considérable lors des
révolutions arabes c'est elle qui assure
la gouvernance pratique la gestion des
nombreuses applications les arbitrages
entre les différents contributeurs
la reconnaissance on pense nous dans
notre étude que la reconnaissance de la
société civile n'est pas assez n'est pas
assez importante et que elle tarde à
venir vis-à-vis des autres acteurs qui
sont les acteurs économiques et qui sont
les états on sait aussi que la société
civile est très peu représenté à
Bruxelles et moi je vous propose puisque
je suis là pour vous proposer des choses
je vous propose euh peut-être de
s'inspirer de l'exemple du Brésil qui
lui associe la société civile par
exemple on l'a vu dans le projet du
Marco civil
d'Internet donc voilà je pense que c'est
important nous pays des droits de
l'homme d'associer la société civile
peut-être à la prochaine loi que que
nous prépare fleur pèlerin droit et
liberté
numérique et j'en viens à la deuxième
partie qui est donc la gouvernance donc
là c'est j'ai traité bon la de la
gouvernance sur Internet euh je vais
m'intéresser maintenant à la gouvernance
de l'Internet on sait que les États-Unis
ont une respons abilité historique dans
le fonctionnement et dans le
développement d'Internet et c'est vrai
qu'ils sont très soucieux de de
conserver leur
hégémonie et on sait que depuis 15 ans
c'est la CAN qui donc qui est une
association de droit privé américain et
qui est sous contrat avec le Département
américain et
qui décide de la politique d'attribution
des nom de domaines via son
DNS j'ai écoutterz attentivement le
votre audition de FAD Chade le président
de la CAN et il était très satisfait de
d'avoir que que l'can a bien rempli sa
mission et c'est vrai qu'on peut
reconnaître que la mission a été bien
remplie je pense ne pas avoir été très
complaisante avec la CAN dans mon étude
et je pense que
euh je pense que je ne suis pas la seule
que cette association est de plus en
plus contestée surtout par les pays
émergents et les pays en voie de
développement qui supporte pas d'avoir
cette subordination vis-à-vis d'une
association de droits privé américain et
on peut le comprendre d'autre part lors
de mes auditions je me suis aperçu que
la canne souffrait d'une gouvernance peu
transparente mal organisée et dont la
légitimité est de plus en plus contestée
surtout depuis Dubaï on a vu qu'elle
était vraiment que que le bloc dont je
parlais le bloc occidental avec les
États-Unis voulait absolument justement
confier la gestion de ses ressources
critique à l'ut plutôt que de de la
laisser à la canne donc ça a été une
grosse opération de ing avec un nombre
impressionnant avec un nombre
impressionnant de la délégation
américaine pour justement appuyer et
conforter cette position de la
CAN je pense aussi que les Révolution la
les révélations de l'affire prisme euh
ont remis en cause la suprématie des
États-Unis et et de et donc du même coup
la canne et qu'il est envisagé de plus
en plus de rechercher des solutions
alternatives et je pense que ce en
écoutant vot votre les audit donc
l'audition parce que je n'aurais pas pu
vous tenir ses propos avant si je
n'avais pas entendu FAD Chad je vous
remercie pour cette vidéo puceque je
n'ai pas eu le le compte-rendu de de
l'édition je pense que FAD chad a bien
compris que c'est la situation est très
critique pour la CAN et donc en homme
très intelligent et et surtout très fin
politicien il a fait plusieurs gestes
politiques qui annonce un changement
stratégique de la CAN donc il par sa
volonté afficher de d'accentuer plus ou
moins donc ses efforts de transparence
et il a parlé aussi
d'internationalisation
euh il a aussi il s'est associé en
octobre dernier à la déclaration commune
de montevideéo qui était quand même un
geste politique
fort avec les 10 organisations qui
gèrent les aspects techniques du
fonctionnement d'Internet
IETF W3C internet architecture board il
s'est rapproché de dil maroussef très
remonté contre l'espionnage de la NSA
puisque elle a elle a fait savoir à la
tribune de l'ONU le Brésil est donc
devenu pour lui un interlocuteur de
choix parce que il aimerait bien
s'affranchir quand même de son
encombrant tuteur je
crois à ce sujet donc je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure le Brésil organise un un forum
sur la
gouvernance et puis le c'est ce point
que j'aimerais sur lequel j'aimerais
justement approfondir il va renforcer le
rôle du GAC qui est le gouvernemental à
commit c'est vrai que les États et j'ai
eu l'occasion de auditionner monsieur
Blarel et David Martinon les États n'ont
qu'un rôle consultatif au sein du GAC Le
Gac fait partie donc un des comités qui
vous connaissez peut-être l'organisation
de de la CAN et c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont
un rôle que consultatif et qu' n'ont
toujours pas de droit de vote et je je
pense pouvoir enfin le dire au sein de
cette Assemblée mais David martinau me
confier je crois que vous l'avez reçu me
confi que c'était assez humiliant quand
même pour des hauts-fonctionnaires
d'avoir juste un rôle de consultation et
ne pas avoir un rôle de
décision
euh donc je pense d'ailleurs la Chine a
on peut le souligner quand même je
parlais quand même qu'elle avait un
intranet mais elle a quand même dès que
FAD dès que Laan je crois pas que
c'était à l'époque de fadish Chad mais
dès que Laan a a
donc renforcé et puis et puis et puis
ouvert un petit pe plus le gar que la
Chine a adopté une démarche très
pragmatique et elle a réintégré comme
d'autres pays qui le composent ça a
permis aussi et c'est peut-être ceci
explique cela ça a permis aussi
l'expansion du DNS avec les nouveaux les
les nouveaux gTLD en chinois en Cyril en
arabe et
cetera FAD Chade on sait qu'il veut donc
internationaliser l'can et ilémancipé
définitivement du commerce du
département de commerce américain il
souligné qu'il avait l'accord de de son
conseil d'administration mais je pense
qu'il a besoin quand même en dernier
ressort aussi de de l'accord de son du
département de commerce américain ce qui
n'a pas l'air d'être pour l'instant
acquis est-ce que les États-Unis sont
prêts à perdre la mamise sur la
gouvernance d'Internet c'est une
question à poser et et et ça pour
l'instant je crois pas qu'il est la
réponse et nous non
plus je pense que la Canan souhaite donc
enfin c'est pas que je pense c'est que
Lacan a précisé qui souhaitait passer de
du statut de société californienne à une
société internationale peut-être basée à
Genève un petit peu comme l'IUT qui est
aussi situé à
Genève la proposition que je que je fais
pour votre pour votre étude pour votre
mission sur la gouvernance d'Internet
même si je comme je vous le répète je ne
suis pas quelqu'un qui est très
complaisante vis-à-vis de l'can c'est
que je pense qu'il faut justement sauter
sur l'occasion essayer d'accompagner
intelligemment euh cette mutation de
cette émancipation ce mouvement
d'émancipation de l' Canan du
gouvernement des États-Unis parce que
qu'on le veuille ou non la CAN assure
quand même la stabilité d'Internet et
qu'il est même si je suis même si j'ai
mentionné des alternatives comme open
rout je pense que pour l'instant la
canne c'est est difficile à il est
difficile de remplacer la canne comme ça
au pied levé et à ce sujet je pense
qu'il faut encourager cette démarche et
que l'Union européenne pour le coup a un
vrai rôle à jouer dans cette dans cette
émancipation je il est vrai que l'Union
européenne souhaite aussi de nouvelles
règles comme le Brésil mais je crois que
ça a été dit tout à l'heure elle est
handicapée par un manque de cohésion et
de stratégie
politique en faisant des recherches je
me suis rendu compte qu'en 1998
d'ailleurs je je je le mentionne dans
mon étude l'Union européenne avait été
un acteur important alors des
discussions relatives à la mise relative
à la mise en place de la CAN et mais
elle n'avait pas fait valoir ses ses
prérogatives et donc c'est c'est dommage
parce que elle aurait pu justement
mettre en place un contrôle
international à ce moment-là
elle a même joué je crois un rôle
significatif dans la création du Comité
des gouvernements placé auprès de la CAN
et donc je pense que justement l'Union
européenne doit s'organiser pour être
pour être efficace et pour être et pour
accompagner ce mouvement d'émancipation
de la CAN sans être naïf en étant très
pragmatique
euh je pense aussi je pense et je donc
je l'affirme devant cette assemblée je
pense que le le Gak peut être un élément
clé euh dans le dans le dispositif de la
de cette future Acan qui se dessine et
je pense que l'Union européenne doit le
faire
évoluer voilà donc euh
en l'objectif donc est de réformer ce
comité pour prendre des décisions
transparentes clair équitbl avec des
règles connues de tous et donc là je
vais vous lire un petit peu parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai essayé de lister un
petit peu quels seraient les les quels
seraient les les
prérogatives pour ce ce futur GAC et
donc je je pense qu'il serait important
que le rôle de ce comité donc soit plus
stratégique plus tionnelle qu'il n'est
actuellement je pense que les
délégations doivent s'organiser de
manière plus professionnelle avec une
application des capital la seiorité des
représentants envoyer plus de diplomates
pour les aspects politiques je pense
qu'il faut accroître sa diversité
géographique je pense qu'il faut aussi
former les délégations dont je parlais
qui étaient donc les pays indécis et il
faut les former pour justement qu'ils
puissent se positionner et non pas
uniquement leur donner de l'argent comme
fait comme on fait actuellement je pense
qu'il faut donner des moyens au
secrétariat du GAC
et voilà l'Europe peut s'organiser en
formant un bloc plus uni et plus étouffé
qu'aujourd'hui parce que la division
qu'elle la division ou alors l'absence
de de de pays concernés par les enjeux
du numérique empêche les les Européens
de peser dans ces
discussions au sein du GAC et je pense
que l'Europe doit faire force de
proposition au sein du GAC et parler si
possible en premier parce que c'est pas
souvent le cas et voilà quand à la
France je pense queussi elle peut faire
elle doit être une force de proposition
en Europe et à la Canan elle
est je je peux malheureusement enfin
déplorer que pour l'instant même au plus
haut niveau il n'y a pas vraiment une
prise de conscience de ces enjeux de la
gouvernance
d'Internet je pense que la elle doit
mobiliser la francophonie que la
francophonie l'OIF pourrait former ses
membres à la gouvernance d'Internet et
enfin je pense
que la France peut accompagner l'can
dans cette volonté aussi de
s'enraacinant en Europe j'ai entendu que
FAD Chad avait dit qu'il ouvrait des
bureaux à Singapour et à Istanbul
pourquoi pas en France faudrait faudrait
lui poser la question
voilà merci beaucoup madame je vais
passer la parole à à Catherine main de
oui merci de votre exposé j'aurais une
question un peu spécifique à à vous
poser j'ai noté que dans le rapport vous
avez bien identifié un certain nombre de
de sujets que j'avais moi-même
identifié au rang desquels on trouve les
les grands enjeux la menace la
neutralité du Net la protection des
données personnelles la cyber
criminalité la cyber
sécurité forcément vous évoquezvous la
protection de la diversité linguistique
et culturelle que vous venez juste
d'évoqué à travers la défense de la
Francophonie j'ai j'ai cru comprendre
ainsi que le défi au
environnemental que génère cette
nouvelle économie est-ce que vous
pourriez être un petit peu plus précise
et développer ce que vous entendez par
là alors le défi environnemental ainsi
que la protection de la diversité
culturelle et linguistique ah bon je
crois que sur la diversité culturelle et
linguistique il est vrai qu'Internet
comme je l'ai dit a été a été euh
euh a été le précarré des États-Unis
donc c'est vrai que la la langue
anglaise prédomine sur Internet et qu'il
était important euh justement
de de justement de de d'essayer de
contrer un petit peu cette hégémonie de
la langue anglaise c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous ai parlé justement de
la Francophonie parce que je pense que
la France a une carte à jouer un
importante avec cette avec
l'Organisation internationale de la
Francophonie de façon à
justement former et former les pays de
la de la Francophonie à la gouvernance
d'Internet c'est pour l'instant un sujet
qui est vraiment très confidentiel
concernant le défi environnemental c'est
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet que j'ai
abordé et qui n'a pas été qui bon que
j'ai dû mettre puisque nous sommes le
Conseil Économique
euh le conseil économique sociale et
environnemental mais c'est pas quelque
chose qui est vraiment pour le coup ma
spécialité donc ça me serait difficile
de vous en de vous en parler plus en
détail voilà c'est vrai que ce que je
peux vous dire simplement c'est que
l'utilisation des puces RFID euh
euh bon est un est un problème est un
problème important concernant justement
le la comment vous dire la
euh l'environnement et puis surtout on
se disait que le recyclage des de tout
ce qui était mobile et cetera nous
posait problème donc on s'est dit que
c'était important de le de le préciser
dans l'étude voilà
euh dans
votre étude vous utilisez l'expression
pluralisme ordonné oui en évoquant euh
une gouvernance je reprends votre titre
ouverte et
équitable
préciser un petit
peu il y a quelque chose qui vous gêne
dans cette expression
ah pluralisme écoutez ce qui était
curieux ce qui est curieux dans cette
étude c'est que lorsqu'on a lorsque j'ai
commencé à à m'y intéresser et et
maintenant je n'ai plus du tout la même
approche c'est pas que je n'ai plus du
tout la même approche c'est que je me
suis fait une opinion un petit peu
plus un peu moins consensuel disons je
me suis rendu compte qu'en fin de compte
il y avait
des comment vous dire je me suis laissée
un petit peu entraîner par par mes
auditions très par mes inditions
notamment celle de Bertrand la chapelle
de de Monsieur blerel de Monsieur
Martinon de des institutionnels qui ont
fait qui m'ont fait passer des éléments
de
langage et qui m'ont et qui maintenant
ne me satisfont plus donc je ne sais pas
si jeu ai à nouveau cette expression
tout
simplement c'est une une expression qui
émane des des auditions que vous avez
des éléments oui de langage que j'ai pu
que j'ai pu euh voilà qu'on a qu'on
a que j'ai pu voilà avoir lors de mes
auditions très bien ben
écoutez merci beaucoup de de cette
contribution merci de votre rapport et
puis d'avoir eu la gentillesse de venir
le le commenter ici et d'y ajouter des
des commentaires
supplémentaires c'est une bonne
collaboration entre nos deux assemblées
donc merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à
cet échange peut-être voulez-vous
ajouter quelque chose je vois non
simplement le fait que
je je je voulez bon pe peut-être vous
parler du du forum si ça vous
intéressait savoir parce que c'est vrai
que j'avais eu un un l'idée de créer un
forum sur la gouvernance d'Internet
suite à cette étude comme je vous l'ai
dit j'ai un petit peu évolué dans ce
sens-l
euh je me suis rendu compte qu'en fin de
compte cette les for le forum sur la
gouvernance d'Internet qui est une prop
enfin qui a été donc euh proposé après
le SMSI de 2002 et 2005 est une est un
forum qui qui donc prne la gouvernance
multiacteur donc avec les acteurs les
acteurs publics les acteurs privés et la
société civile et c'est vrai que
cette cette j'allais dire cette
formule me paraît pas très pas très
efficace dans le sens où c'est pour ça
que je vous ai parlé du Gak aujourd'hui
parce que j'aiessayé de voir en quoi la
gouvernance comment comment comment on
pouvait interagir comment on pouvait
essayer de justement de d'interagir sur
cet écosystème d'Internet et je me je me
rends compte que le forum sur la
gouvernance d'Internet n'est pas le
meilleur outil voilà donc je voulais
aussi le préciser je l'avais beaucoup
j'avais pensé dans mon étude que c'était
justement la trisième voie entre d'un
côté donc les l'autorégulation de
l'autre le contrôle d'internet et que
ces miracles le forum pouvait être une
solution j'en suis revenu aussi voilà je
voulais aussi le préciser voilà pour
cette audition qui s'est tenue début
mars a Sénat et qui concernait donc la
gouvernance mondiale d'Internet plus
précisément le rôle et la stratégie de
l'Union européenne dans cette
gouvernance mondiale vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site
surpusenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 19h pour 24h
Sénat présenté par Delphine Girard très
bonne fin de journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires